Coenen whoops you look incredible you
always do but I love that dress you do
this is maybe the right way to express
it but yeah you feel right now yeah you
know how I feel right now what
well terrified of course but yeah but it
also slightly uncomfortable but thank
you for liking the dress
I said uncomfortable I don't know you
look absolutely amazing problem problems
with like sort of feeling I don't know
this kind of version of myself right
you saw the clip yeah the plaid version
yeah that's that's how you're the most
comfortable with my comforts it's so
funny or you're so incredibly beautiful
and you're poor you're wearing this
wonderful dress and everyone thinks you
look really sexy but you feel
self-conscious about it I feel
uncomfortable every moment of my life oh
my god everybody we were meant to be
together I know really do you feel like
people don't know that people don't know
that about there's like that the
juxtaposition I think a little bit of
like being an extrovert in terms of like
performance right but then it ultimately
an introvert yeah you know I I know what
you mean which is if there's an audience
I get very excited and very happy and
then sometimes I'll be home and
literally like a neighbor will come to
the door and my wife will be might will
say like oh the the you know mr. Jones
is here not be like I'm scared he's a
murderer which is uh adds to it good
next time you could come in your plaid
version absolutely we wouldn't
however you're most comfortable however
you're most comfortable I'm not gonna
lie I like this a lot
the ventilating but I love that / you
like the pearl I love the Pearl I've
been doing that since I was a boy and I
was shy around girls the one thing I
would do when they run is go back and
they would they would laugh and I that
would ease the tension and now here I am
as a 38 year old man still good I wake
up at you know 3:00 in the morning and I
can't get back to sleep and I'll listen
to like NPR but a better idea would I
wish I could have like a little ear wig
and just you Perrine we could arrange
this I could just I could Crouch by your
bedside and then just sit Coenen yeah
thank you thanks for being here now I
can go back to inspiring comatose yeah
no one puts people to sleep like Conan
O'Brien thank you scrap turns on every
chair out that was somebody that got
elbowed awake they just
you're like go and go huh
you